I get asked a lot of questions about
moocs by viewers and by people I run
into conferences or talks sometimes
people are asking me dr. Sadler why
don't you produce your own MOOC and I'll
talk about that in a few moments some of
the inherent difficulties involved with
that but a lot of people are asking so
you know how should I view MOOCs how
should I regard this because there's a
lot of hype back and forth a lot of its
negative a lot of it's overly positive
and with any sort of new reorganization
of educational practices involving
technology we don't actually know how
some of this stuff is going to pan out
but I think that at this point in time
we can we can give verdicts about some
of it and I think now is the time to
actually do so so that's what I want to
do in this video this is not going to
talk about all the ins and outs of MOOCs
what I'm going to be doing here is is
running through a few different basic
points about about the format the
structure the general idea and the
structure the sociological effects that
MOOCs have within the education sphere
and also within the broader sphere of
culture is mediated through the internet
the Technosphere that I'm involved in
like it or not i'm going to give you my
views and my views are pretty guardedly
negative i'm not a big MOOC supporter i
see some legitimate roles for them in
some areas but i think that in large
part they pose a lot of a lot of
problems a lot of dangers many of them
stemming from people who are overly
optimistic or are just plain gullible
when it when it comes to them so I'll
get to that in a few moments let's tell
at first what is a MOOC just basic
knowledge it's its massive it's an
acronym massive open online classes or
courses and like some commentators have
pointed out these are kind of slippery
terms how massive is
massive does that mean having a hundred
people in the class or 10,000 what does
open mean does it mean that they're free
because now some of the MOOCs are
actually talking about you know pricing
options does it mean that anybody can
get in without any prereqs online of
course you know well what exactly
accounts is online and what components
are going to going to be delivered
online and how's that going to work and
then courses are these are these really
courses do they have all of the the not
just bells and whistles but the
necessary integral components of an
educational course we're getting to the
point now where people are actually
talking about putting entire curriculum
into to a MOOC format which is kind of a
dizzying thought and there there be even
you know greater need for figuring out
just what exactly these terms mean and I
see people kind of all over the map with
this now some of the MOOCs are in the
process or in the business of eventually
offering credit a lot of them give you
certificates of completion there are
always web-based that's that's an
integral part of being online but they
use a variety of different platforms
some of them are being developed by
institutions that are already in the
education business some of them are like
new startups you know they're not just
partnerships like at X there are
actually new businesses like udemy or
Coursera which which are functioning
like like corporations but but
originally intended to transform the
educational landscape and what we got to
ask ourselves is how are these things
structured what are what are the ideas
behind the way that they're supposed to
work how do they actually work in
practice and what sort of mission creep
has started to go on with them as well
now one other thing that I do need to
say is I mentioned a few companies
already like
you're Demi and Coursera iTunes U is
also involved in this sort of thing in a
slightly more tangential way there's
other companies sort of champing at the
bit to get into this google is is you
know got its own things in the
background going on there's there's a
moop dot org initiative going on and
nobody's quite sure how all these are
going to pan out but one of the things
that you see all of them saying along
with a lot of other new players in the
educational marketplace you might say
are that they are there to transform
education in positive ways and why would
that be necessary well it's felt that
there is a real crisis and I would
actually say that there's a number of
different crises all kind of
intersecting with each other and and
causing a kind of feedback phenomenon
with each other in education in
particularly in post-secondary education
this is a much larger topic I can't do
more than just skim the surface but
there there are real problems out there
for what we call stakeholders the people
who are want to know that education is
actually taking place like parents
government agencies that are putting up
money the institution's themselves the
donors students themselves should be
very concerned about whether they're
actually learning anything that's that's
genuinely sticking so there's a problem
of you know assessment of student
learning and holding teachers to some
sort of standards and holding
administrators to some sort of standards
and institutions as holes there are a
lot of other problems as well you know
technology by by its very nature is
something that we use we come to rely
upon and yet it's also disruptive it
offers new possibilities we're
encountering students who have been much
more informed by technology than those
of previous generations although you
know
to go way way back to find generations
that weren't already greatly influenced
by by television that haven't sort of
learned some things from from the
internet revolution and educational
institutions also have this
intrinsically altruistic bed to them of
wanting to to serve there's this there's
this great feeling that many people are
not getting the sort of access to
education that they wanted to be given
that perhaps they deserve is a human
right that's a debatable issue but I
just want to say that some people view
it that way there's the entire
developing world there's all these
people who because of rising college
costs and the shrunken economy can't
afford to go to school or are living in
places i encounter this through through
the videos that I produce I get comments
from people who are in foreign countries
and they can't go through their state
institution to learn philosophy for
example because that's reserved for a
certain elite and they don't belong to
that they're in a you know you know tech
based class or we call vocational trades
so there's a lot of different things
coming together and I think a lot of
people think that MOOCs are the solution
and that's where a lot of the the
initial hype came from and that's where
the backlash against that is coming from
what we want to do is look at this very
carefully because really when it comes
down to it so much has been invested in
MOOCs they're here to stay they're not
going to go away and they are
transforming the educational landscape
to some degree and they're going to
continue doing so so we don't want to
just be you know luddites and say oh
wait with the MOOCs you know at the same
time we need to be very careful about
how we endorse them
which ones we endorse because we
shouldn't forget that these are
associated with particular institutions
with particular companies agents who we
don't actually have control over who may
have their own agendas and I'll talk
about that in a few moments and it may
in fact be doing things without even
realizing it that are reinforcing some
some of the already existing problems in
academia and in the larger marketplace
of ideas that academia is supposed to be
serving so what I really want to focus
on is is this notion that MOOCs are
democratizing education I want to say
that's false why do I want to say that's
false if we take it in any really
substantive sense of democratizing as in
you know widening the capacity for
people to actually be involved to be
engaged to be think about what democracy
involves democracy is not just everybody
gets a vote Aristotle had this right
when he said democracy not only means
that everybody who's a you know the
voting class gets to vote they also have
the chance to hold offices they have the
chance not only to root be ruled but to
rule I don't think that that is actually
present in the way that MOOCs are being
done and I think that MOOCs are
contributing to forces that are actually
hindering that we're roading that no
I'll get to that in a few moments there
is a sort of you know opening of access
to two people but we have to talk about
who's actually taking advantage of that
and who's able to take advantage of that
they certainly are disrupting education
they're shaking things up I don't know
that they're disrupting education in
very substantive go down to the bedrock
kind of ways where colleges and
these are now like reshaping their their
entire curricula that's though what's
being proposed that's right now more or
less in the realm of the imagination and
in the realm of discourse not in the
realm of actual structural change that
is being implemented but that's a very
important thing to to keep an eye on
democratizing education would mean
opening up education content wise to a
greater number of agents voices
perspectives MOOCs are doing that in
some ways and they're also hindering
that in in other ways in my view and a
lot of this discourse about MOOCs really
depends on making a very strong
distinction between MOOCs that are
involved with what we might call
convergent fields it's a computer
programming or micro economics or things
like that and then what they often call
divergent fields which include many of
the social sciences definitely the
humanities where there's a lot of
different particular perspectives and
it's not expected that we all have to
get on the same page because we're
aiming at is less providing the ability
to regurgitate knowledge back or to do a
certain task and more the ability to
think about what we're doing to give
reasons to another person that that
person if they're reasonable might in
turn find reasonable to to examine and
to entertain and I don't think MOOCs are
that good at that yet in part because i
don't think the institutions that are
deeply involved with that are very good
at that so there's a number of different
things i want to talk about with respect
to the criticisms that could be may
MOOCs and i think that there's there's
really five main ones that that i think
myself are compelling there's a lot of
other criticisms you can make to like
you can't possibly teach you know intro
to philosophy in a meaningful way to
2,000 people all at the same time you
know and there's ways to sort of get
around that that the MOOCs are
experimenting with and I have to admit
some of those ways actually make quite a
bit of a good sense but here's the
things that I think are happening what
is a very practical point that I want to
make there are only so many hours in any
given day so if we are expanding the
range of educational options we're
actually contributing to you know what's
called the paradox of choice where it
becomes harder to choose what we're
going to do and things the options that
we have often paralyzed this and then
become meaningless in the process we're
also generating if MOOCs really catch on
a society of educational consumers who
then have to choose between these
different things and all the time that's
spent consuming most of the time is also
time that can't be spent actively
producing now there are some ways around
that you can design assignments for
example so they have they require
somebody to do some research which in a
way is consuming although actual
research is much more active I'm not
sure about MOOCs being able to teach
that sort of thing very very well
there's a hands-on component that that's
needed with that in any case there's
only so many hours in the day and if
we're going to expand our involvement in
being students which i'm not i'm not
against i think that's a great thing we
have less time to be
content producers to be knowledge
communicators to be engaged so there's a
real danger there and I'm not saying
that MOOCs can't address this but it is
a real danger the second thing is i
think that MOOCs are likely to lead to a
kind of homogenous a shin not only of
education but of the experience of
education one of the things that i think
is what it is a great strength of the
American educational system is the fact
that it's not a system as opposed to
some of the other state systems
supplemented by you know a few private
schools that are prevalent in other
countries we have a plethora of
different models different schools that
are known for different strengths it's
really you know if you had enough
knowledge and it's very difficult to get
the kind of knowledge that's required in
this respect but if you have the right
knowledge about what educational
institutions are like you could actually
find a place for every single kind of
student where they would flourish if
they were willing to put in the time you
could even like take the ones who are
you know can if you about flourishing
and putting in the time and have schools
that are well suited to them where they
kind of specialize in that sort of thing
we deliver education online we deliver
education in in massive classes and
small online classes I teach some of
those myself I know what that's like we
have not just one single platform for
that there's blackboard and canvas and
sakai and Moodle there are so many
different options I think that MOOCs in
some respects present a danger of
flattening that out and saying here is
the standard now this is what we need to
conform to so I see that as I see that
as a real
problem another big problem with MOOCs
at this point in time is that it's
pretty difficult to assess their
effectiveness in generating student
learning lasting learning and you know
exactly the same problem that was noted
in academically adrift the the famous
you know wake-up call from about five
years ago that that hit the the academic
establishment like a load of bricks the
problem that that they noted in that
study was that the the better
institutions are turning out students
who know quite a bit because they took
in students who knew quite a bit and
already have the skills that were needed
to to get by in college and they didn't
improve an awful lot in that for your
time of Education for a six year
actually the same thing that's happening
with MOOCs they're taking in the highly
educated for the most part not just in
America but worldwide people started
actually studying this most of the
people who are doing MOOCs are people
who already have college degrees so it's
kind of like cherry picking the
experimental batch that you're going to
work on it's a hell of a lot easier to
teach people who already know how the
system works and how to proceed through
it and who already have the experience
of having made it through and you
probably don't even have to have them
write papers because they're there you
know already thinking along those lines
taking the general population is an
entirely different matter and if we want
to say that MOOCs are really the way to
go we need to have genuine assessment of
them I don't see that being done I don't
see a genuine assessment of student
learning being done in a lot of places
even in traditional education it's very
hit and miss if you're in if you're
under sacks the
the you know the accreditation body for
the southern schools it's a lot more
rigorous than say under some of the
other regional bodies then even those
are kind of hit miss some institution
could censured other institutions that
probably should get censored don't
because the investigators don't look
into it the interviewers don't ask the
right questions and schools right up
self reports and people believe that so
there's a real issue here with
assessment and an assessment is
important because you will if you want
to make policy decisions about where
resources ought to be going where where
students will have to be directed you
need to have some evidence to base those
on and it's got to be real assessment
not just proxy assessment not just sort
of make work assessment it's got to
really be assessing are the students
improving in skills like written
communication critical thinking these
content areas that they're supposed to
be studying so that takes a lot of work
a lot of careful designing the fourth
thing I want to talk about and as a
caution when it comes to MOOCs they're
basically working in a new corporate
environment particularly the ones like
Coursera and you Demi there's a great
article that I'm going to link to in the
description of this video talking about
the pivot that you Demi has done udemy
was talking all this great you know
lingo about transforming education and
they're going to be this disruptive
force and it's going to be for the best
and it's going to widen education for
everybody and everybody is going to have
the chance to like study with world
class instructors all sounds pretty good
right and now they're starting to sound
an awful lot more like traditional
corporations they're they're more or
less training people for corporate jobs
and their
interested in their bottom lines and
whether they can be profitable and this
is where things are going to go I mean
these companies they may start out
having this great vision of making
education accessible for everybody
that's a tough thing to sustain over
time and you know you can say well what
about you know people getting big grants
you know from say the Melissa and Bill
Gates Foundation or you know Ford
Foundation or pick whoever you like
those always come with strings those
always come with some sort of agenda
that's that's being pushed and we should
be I think weary of that and I I'm not
you know trying to say this guy is
following or anything like that but just
not having a direct corporate
involvement doesn't mean that you don't
think like like a corporation and start
it starts to lead to to something that
roads the educational aspect of it as
soon as it becomes administrators and
you know corporate types and
administrators basically our corporate
types these days and it's no longer
educators who are running these these
things you should be very very wary
about any claims that that are being
made about widening education
democratizing it opening up for
everybody now I save the best for last
and here's where the criticisms that I'm
going to make our are not being made by
by quite as many people the criticisms
that I've made so far are not
particularly original I think a lot of
people are worried about these sorts of
things they're probably not as is given
distressing a speaking of the importance
of assessment as I am because I'm kind
of an evangelist for authentic
assessment but a lot of people are
saying those what I think the real
problem with MOOCs is is they're not
democratizing education they're actually
generating two different classes of
people and they're eliminating another
class too if they catch on they're
opening up opportunities for those who
are in the elite who are well-connected
who went to the right schools who teach
at the right schools who have the right
contacts who have the opportunities or a
very very small class of academics to
teach a massive swath of people who are
going to be essentially just consumers
and are never going to have the chance
so you know every once in a while there
will be an aberration from this will be
the lucky one who gets in to make it up
into that class academia is already
quite a bit like that but right now
there's actually a lot of people in
between Tim there's all the adjuncts and
that's what that's a topic that we need
to talk about some other time but
there's all these other people teaching
at institutions that are not involved
with MOOCs but are being encouraged to
consume i remember when i was at
fayetteville state university they gave
us ipads for this this pilot program and
then they showed us itunes university
and they started telling us you know you
guys could could have your students
watching these videos you could you
could have students watching world-class
professors giving lectures on the topics
that that you're teaching and you know a
few of the teachers alike so you want us
to direct our students to not pay
attention to to us in class we're not
good enough to lecture for them we
should have these people lecture for
them instead and of course there was a
lot of backpedaling no no we're not
saying that this is just just a resource
but there is a lot of pushing of this
you know and it's interesting there were
there been a couple cases that have come
up recently that I think are very
relevant and and say a lot about this
kind of situation so Michael Sandow
who's a you know brilliant philosopher I
like his work quite a bit he has done a
number of lectures that you can find on
youtube and they're also incorporated
into a MOOC about justice the nature of
justice so it's in political theater
political philosophy what made the
headlines is a number of San Jose
professors refused to teach and teach I
mean he's teaching the class isn't he if
it's a MOOC they refuse to use the the
resources that the school wanted them to
use from that that course in their
course because they saw that what was
happening is they were being squeezed
out it's very difficult to compete with
a Sandell it's difficult to compete with
it and he's not into this business he
just lets himself be videotaped all the
time ajijic or a peter singer or any of
these sort of people as a matter of fact
you don't even have to have a really
great name recognition you just need to
come from an elite University you just
need to be teaching at Harvard and
people will take you more seriously than
if you're teaching at say well even like
Vassar and if you're teaching at Vassar
you'll probably be taken a bit more
seriously than teaching at marist and if
you're teaching at marist a bit more
seriously than say teaching at FSU you
know and there's a same thing goes with
the state schools there's the elite ones
there's the they call them you know
public IVs and then there's everybody
else and if you're in the everybody else
class you're being sort of pushed out of
that middle intermediate range into the
consumers and you're being treated as
somebody who's basically just fit to
start the videotape play start the
projector running start the slides
remember those old film strips not
really to teach not really to design not
really to implement on your own except
with the guidance that's coming
from from on high there's a real danger
of that no that may be okay in some
fields that is poison for philosophy for
history for political theory any of the
humanities really any of the social
sciences that are that are even you know
self aware of them as being social
sciences with the past a history it
would be poison for the arts it would be
poison I think even for business I think
we want business professors who actually
know their stuff are practicing their
craft in the classroom and who are
acknowledged as somebody to measure up
to by the students not just some schmuck
to turn things on and turn out the
lights when everybody leaves now you
could say well you know dr. Sadler
you're really overstating the case MOOCs
aren't trying to do anything like that
um there are proposals to do that sort
of thing and it appeals to the elites of
both the left and the right and it also
appeals to people who are saying hi we
need to look at the bottom line there's
this a recent case with this junior
professor I don't know if I'm
pronouncing his name right Mitchell jr.
who is a sociology professor taught a
very very popular course for Coursera
and Coursera decided that they wanted to
license the course so that they could
like they could have colleges buy it and
then colleges could save money by not
not keeping all these professors to
teach this course he could teach the
course instead for them
and he refused what was really
interesting is he said I'm not going to
do anything that would actually like put
other academics jobs at risks at risk
now what do you left out of that
explanation and what nobody actually
brought up at the time well why should
we care I mean if it's more efficient to
have one superstar professor with a MOOC
who's got a great you know reputation
has the leisure time to write books and
give talks and you know is got all the
connections to get it you know teach for
Coursera because Coursera doesn't just
hire anybody they like the elite
institutions if he really can provide a
better product than these other
professors well screw them reorganize
the economy right it's just becoming
more efficient he didn't say I can't
provide you with something as good or
better than what these other professors
aren't providing instead he just said we
gotta let that we got to keep them you
know in in their positions why should we
keep them in their positions if they're
not actually contributing value I don't
have any problem with that conservative
usually conservative argument about
teacher performance but i do think
teachers are performing that's the issue
i don't think that one guy with a MOOC
however brilliant armed with you know
computer grading of essays or a whole
bunch of TAS who you know labour behind
the scenes to keep the discussions going
because one guy can actually engage in
conversation with a thousand people let
alone ten thousand i don't think that
the MOOC can actually deliver the kind
of education that good college
professors can do and I think that we
want to keep sort of intermediary strata
in place of good college professors who
are much bigger than that small elite
who gets the you know the bulk of the
money the notoriety the opportunity
is and all that that's a that's a crappy
system to begin with but it's a hell of
a lot better than just pushing all of
them into the realm of education
consumers now you might respond by
saying well dr. Sadler what if they you
know created a MOOC for you that's not
going to happen Coursera deals with
institutions that X does the same thing
there may be a few organizations out
there that are looking to do it for for
individuals but I know I wouldn't have
the time to grade a thousand papers and
if you're not actually requiring people
to do some writing now you can do peer
grading and all that sort of stuff but
that requires it an awful lot of
training on your part so you've got to
put in that work somewhere no matter
what and can one professor put that in
with a thousand students I don't think
so my Dean is actually concerned about
having overloads with 35 students in an
online class as opposed to 30 students
in an online class because he thinks the
quality of education might be going down
and he's right there is only so much
time for an educator to actually devote
to the one-on-one interactions and the
group interactions that are required day
in day out throughout the semester for
real education to take place we want
that middle strata there we need people
we need a diversity of people teaching
all of these subjects and all MOOCs are
really doing is putting something else
up here at the apex what it really
reminds me of it is a story that's told
about Heidegger Martin Heidegger was a
philosopher he thought that not that
many people can actually do innovative
work in philosophy so the curricula
should be reorganized in Germany and
everybody should more or less just teach
what they're supposed to teach and just
don't try to think
through too much don't try to do any
original work that'll be left to like
you know the very top philosophers the
ones who actually have a shot at doing
anything innovative interesting the rest
of them should shut up stay in line and
just teach the content I think there's a
real danger of that happening with with
with MOOCs so I think that it leads to
the reinforcement of an already existing
and not very good class system within
academia I don't think that they're
actually disruptive I don't think that
there actually is in large part
Democratic I think there's potential for
MOOCs to do a lot of good but I don't
think that they should supplant
traditional or even smaller online
education I think that that's the way to
go I think that we should be offering
education as widely as we can you notice
I'm all for putting videos for free on
YouTube shooting all sorts of content I
like sites like learnist and smaller you
know startups that are that are trying
to provide educational content to other
people I'm all for that sort of thing
I'm even for the pay sites because I
think educators while I ought to get
paid for creating content particularly
if it's good content I think that that
sort of entrepreneurial entrepreneurial
attitude is a good thing but I think it
should be happening at the lower levels
I don't think that it should be these
massive dinosaurs ruling the land and
pushing everybody else more or less out
of the way unfortunately those tend to
get the most attention and people tend
to to glom onto that I think that what
we really ought to be doing is looking
at the smaller companies the smaller
classes the the people who are
developing good content and figuring out
ways how to link these together how did
to widen that so that we can reach this
this
massive audience of people who do want
to use the internet to enjoy some of the
benefits of education that are available
to them so there is my take on on MOOCs
I'm sure this is going to provoke a lot
of comments I'm willing to entertain any
of those that are within the realm of
reason ability